i sided to start with Lord of the Flies
you know one of the most famous novels
of the 20th century you know it's about
a group of kids that end up on an island
and an inhabited island after an
airplane crash and they have to you know
set set up some kind of society to
survive and it doesn't really work turns
out that civilization is only a very
thin veneer and if you leave this kids
alone even though they went to a really
good British boarding school you know
they were very well behaved but you know
they they turn into savages at least
that's what happens in the novel written
by William Golding it was published in
the 50s and it became you know a huge
bestseller millions and millions of kids
Lord of the Flies as a thing it's like
oh he's gonna go Lord of the Flies like
it's like a shorthand did you have to
read it in school or not yes yes we did
yeah yeah yeah IIIi read it when I was
16 or 17 or something like that and I
still remember you know the the effect
it had on me you know I felt like uh
well that's depressing but maybe this is
more realistic as well no more Harry
Potter for me but then for this book I
decided to to see and find out whether
there's ever been a real life Lord of
the Flies case right has it ever
happened in all world history that real
kids shipwrecked on a real island and
yeah what would have happened so yeah
after a couple of months of research I
did find a case actually in 1965 in
Tonga which is an iron grip in the
Pacific Ocean there were six kids who
were bored of their boring school and
they hated the school meals so what they
decided to do is to steal a boat and get
away now in the first night they ended
up in a storm they drifted for eight
days ended up on this uninhabited island
and survived for 15 months and this how
long nine months yeah fifteen months so
then the crazy thing is that if you if
you look at the real art of flies like
this real story in almost every single
way it's the opposite of the fictional
Lord of the Flies it's a story of
friendship of hope and of resilience and
actually these these guys are still
friends today and I am a necessity
you have a hopefully you're bonded for
life by the fact you got shipwrecked
together and you didn't eat each other
so now you're now you're each other's
like you know Christmas list would we
built like the the lean-to together
exactly